Calcium is the third element in group two
on the periodic table. It’s really very
common. We find it all over the world in all
sorts of minerals. So for example you can
have bones, this is a pelvis of a sheep, I
found it when I was walking one day, you can
see the legs go in there and there.
In here we have some calcium turnings. We’re
storing them in our glove box. This glove
box here is a contraption full of nitrogen,
it’s dry nitrogen so that we can keep our
calcium away from oxygen and away from moisture
as well, because obviously what we don’t
want is when we get our nice very reactive
calcium surface we don’t want it to tarnish
from oxides too quickly before we can react
it with things. So what we have here inside
the bottle are turnings of calcium. Calcium
is quite hard compared to sort of the heavier
group two elements, so strontium and barium,
so it’s harder to file.
Bones are made from calcium phosphate mixed
with some organic material as well and they’re
very strong because of the structure within
the bones. There are all sorts of shells of
molluscs and the like where they use calcium
carbonate from the sea water, getting the
calcium out, reacting with carbon dioxide
and making their shells. And because shells
are made out of calcium carbonate, which dissolves
in acid, people are quite worried about the
effects of global warming. Not the heating
up but when the C02 dissolves into the sea
it makes it more acid, so in principle shells
could start dissolving and some molluscs may
not be able to survive because they just can’t
make their shells.
If I just pour them out so you can see.
Calcium looks metallic than the calcium metal
itself because of the way the electrons behave
in the solid. In fact it is because it is
a very good electrical conductor but the compounds
are all white, because calcium has no free
electrons that can go from one energy level
to another in the way you can say with copper.
So copper sulphate is a beautiful blue colour,
calcium sulphate is white, and it’s actually
colourless, so if you see a big crystal of
calcium sulphate it just looks like glass.
But the white is caused by very small crystals
which scatter the light, just in the same
way that any sort of white powder will scatter
light, flour for example or talcum powder,
anything like that.
Calcium compounds themselves are actually
mostly white, but calcium metal itself, as
you can see we’ve got tarnished parts but
also there are some shiny bits where it’s
untarnished. So you’re actually seeing the
metal the lustre of the metal there as well.
Calcium carbonate dissolves in water saturated
with C02 to make calcium bicarbonate which
is more soluble. And so you can get water,
so called hard water, that has quite high
levels of calcium. And when this percolates
through the ground and comes to a cave it
can then crystallise out and you can get hanging
down pillars of calcium carbonate, which are
called stalactites. And you can have pillars
growing from the floor called stalagmites.
This is a stalagmite from Turkey. One of my
friends called Hugh was really naughty. He
knew I was interested in minerals and he broke
this off from a cave in Turkey about 45 years
ago and brought it and gave it to me so I
was really pleased. And you can see the outside
looks quite blobby, and inside you can see
there are nice crystals of calcium carbonate
because it has grown very, very slowly and
so it can crystalise. And sometimes these
stalagmites and stalactites can grow really
big. And more recently, in the last few years,
people have found huge crystals of calcium
sulphate under the ground. Some of you may
have seen pictures of caves in Mexico where
there are crystals big enough you can actually
walk along them. So there is no danger that
calcium will ever run out, it’s the basis
of cements and concretes, or one of the bases
because then you need other elements like
iron and silica to make the concrete itself,
but calcium is one of the principle components.
We’re going to take calcium chloride, put
it in a flame and do a flame test and see
if we can see the colour of the calcium in
the flame. So as I said before about calcium
compounds, calcium compounds are often white,
and here is a white calcium compound. So I’m
going to put it in the flame and see if we
get any colour. Oh hello, that looks quite
red doesn’t it? Brick red is the classic
calcium colour. Bit orangey to me, might be
a bit of sodium in there, or something like
that. That was our calcium flame test.
The reason that you don’t find lumps of
calcium metal lying around, the way you do
with copper or gold, is that metallic calcium
is very reactive, reacts with water very quickly.
Magnesium doesn’t react because it has a
layer of oxide on the surface, so surprisingly
magnesium is not nearly as reactive as calcium.
You can use magnesium, or its alloys, for
the wheels on your car, go round really fast
because they’re light. You couldn’t have
calcium wheels in your car, well you could,
but the first time it rained your whole car
would go up in flames.
This again what we’ve got is our calcium
chloride, hydrated calcium chloride. We’ve
got a bunch of it on this spatula. I’ll
put it in the flame so that you can see that
it’s burning with a brick red flame which
is characteristic of calcium. It’s kind
of a bit orangey to me as well actually, might
be a bit of sodium or something in there.
Got anymore in there? A little bit.
Many people see calcium as a very English
element, unlike strontium which was discovered
in Scotland, because of the white cliffs of
Dover, the gateway for many people when they
first come to England. They’re made of calcium
carbonate. And so this white colour of chalk
is very characteristic and all over the southern
part of England you find large amounts of
chalk, which in the north of England they
tend to be limestone, which is also calcium
carbonate but a slightly different variety
of calcium carbonate so it’s a yellow or
honey colour because of the impurities of
iron or some other element that’s in it.
Well you need calcium for all sorts of processes
in the body and of course to build up your
bones. Particularly, say in the case of pregnant
women, they need to have calcium for the bones
of the developing baby. But as people get
older the calcium can come out of their bones
and make them very fragile, this is why elderly
people sometimes break their hips and break
their bones so easily. So drinking milk and
eating other sources of calcium are good because
it helps you replenish your bones and keep
a reasonable level of calcium.